before I get into the rest of this video
let me just show this ridiculous hotel
room so I've got a giant bathroom or for
myself that's pretty good and then I've
got two enormous beds I wouldn't even
know what to do with just one of them
and when we get up to the curtains as
there we go as an amazing view of the
Hollywood Hills it's like I don't know
I'm in a place that I'm not supposed to
be and yet this is somehow my hotel room
right now if you go all the way to the
left you can see a giant minion statue
so it's kind of fun to think about the
fact that all the thousands of people
living in this value wake up every
morning looking at a giant statue of a
minion I honestly don't even think that
I'm gonna use much of this room to do
anything in any case I'm just gonna
probably spend my remaining time than I
have here doing homework because I still
have some homework for my home
university so yeah that's what I'm gonna
have to do
[Music]
all right now that we've got that out of
the way what a bit do a little bit of an
introduction of what's actually going on
here so a few weeks ago when I just
arrived back out of Japan I was invited
by frontier to this event and it's a big
event for promotion of Jurassic world
evolution includes a day with developers
and looking at gameplay actually playing
the game yourself before it comes out as
well as a day in Universal Studios so
there's a whole tie-in with this area as
well it's kind of interesting I think
because I never really felt like I
belong here I honestly am placed in this
huge group of enormous youtubers and
then as me but yeah it's really awesome
nonetheless and I can't thank what's
here enough for giving me this
opportunity
so at least I want to make the most of
it and be able to share this whole thing
as much as I can with you guys so I'm
doing a little bit of a vlog again even
though I suck at these things so yeah it
goes hopefully the rest of this thing
will be a little bit more interesting
than me
looking at Los Angeles for my hotel room
and talking to the camera oh and by the
way I also got this amazing goodie bag
which includes a bunch of stuff that I
don't really care about but we've also
got some some some real Dennis value
shaving gel here which is really cool I
don't touch this for too long as I feel
like bad things are gonna happen if I do
that so back in the back it goes so I'm
just gonna speed you through the rest of
this video so the second day really
since the first day was just arriving we
got free tickets to go to Universal
Studios so I went there together with
flux because we were basically the only
people who actually met each other
before this and that was a pretty good
day I do have to say beautiful sign look
at that
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna turn your way
[Music]
well anyway I'm sorry about Netflix so
basically we hung out in Universal
Studios Hollywood for about half a day I
have to say in hindsight this is
probably the worst of the Universal
Studios parks it's quite small and it's
all really nice it's a really beautiful
parks but it's mostly restaurants and
shops a few shows here and there but
really only a few good rides so as for
filling your day we were done with the
entire park after half a day and
honestly I have to say that I do prefer
the Japanese Park but that said this
Park does have mummy the ride which is
an awesome addition to it which I didn't
do so far and it's a really fun ride but
in the end my favorite ride here has to
be Jurassic Park not because we went on
this trip just for Jurassic world I
think it's just a really awesome ride
with great animatronics the scenery is
slightly better than on the Japanese
version I feel even though it's kind of
missing that t-rex at the top it's just
a classic but anyway after that we
headed out into the downtown area I was
shocked and how empty the metro was I
was also shocked at the size of this
pizza but we basically went to Hollywood
which is probably the biggest tourist
trap that I've ever seen so we got out
of there went to the Japanese Village
Little Tokyo and ended up in like Skid
Row and this random street with a bunch
of fake shops and stuff we didn't really
plan out this whole downtown tour but it
was really nice we stopped at the
Bradbury building along the way and
being a big fan of Blade Runner this was
really awesome to see and also went to
the Grand Central Market which is kind
of like one of these European city
markets but in LA and it's really really
cool part of downtown just downtown in
general was a really nice area of the
city I'm not a huge fan of how it just
kind of sprawls into suburbs forever but
I think downtown even if it's less Los
Angeles like is a really cool part of
the city so yeah we went and see some
like arts stuff and of course this
deconstructivist Disney Concert Hall in
the middle of downtown LA which was all
really cool I love the City Hall as well
just this whole park over here was
pretty neat but we had to go back pretty
soon because in the night we had this
awesome party
so yeah frontier invited us to this free
party at a rooftop the middle of
Hollywood that was absolutely insane
ridiculous experience but definitely
really fun met lots of awesome youtubers
there but anyway we had to go to bed
pretty early because the next morning we
had to go into the stage in Universal
Studios the actual studios which is
where the event was held and this is
where we got a lot of embargoed
information which I could pretty much
say at this point but you're gonna have
to watch the gameplay videos for that
kind of stuff this was basically where
we got demos of the game could interview
the developers could just generally hang
around and chat with people and I guess
a stroke of velociraptors well this is
basically where all of the the content
that came out of this was made and this
is really why we were being sent over to
LA in the first place but really it was
really fun as well because I didn't
really have so much to do as I just had
a lot of time to chat with the
developers and check out about the game
what I wanted to check out and there was
really just a very relaxed and cool
atmosphere around here and as you can
see the way that they dressed up the
stage was really awesome as well not to
mention that actually being in Universal
Studios was just insane because this is
not the part that you get to see as a
regular visitor you can't just come here
at all it was kind of difficult to get
in here and actually so I just wanted to
take this chance and take some pictures
and shots of the whole studios as well
just because it's it felt really weird
to actually be there in any case after
we were done with all of that I think it
was about four o'clock in the afternoon
we wanted to meet up with strict officer
because he lives in LA and before we did
that we just had a little bit of time to
check out Santa Monica go to the pier
just visit all of these awesome places
that I've basically seen in movies and
GTA for real
which is also a really cool experience
but the goal here was basically just to
meet up with strict's and we didn't
really do so much specifically just got
some Mexican food
checked out Venice Beach checked out the
area where he lives and then did a huge
drive through the city
we went to like Beverly Hills and went
through the Hollywood Hills to check out
a view of the city I don't really have
any really great shots of this because
my camera doesn't really work with bad
lighting so well but yeah it was a
really great trip so huge thanks
district toaster for doing all of this
for us don't really have any proof other
than this picture that we were all
together so yeah here you go after all
of that I always kind of kicked out of
the Hilton Hotel because the frontier
part of this trip was over and
everything that frontier paid for me was
over as well so I just booked the
cheapest hostel I could find in
Hollywood which was a really cool hostel
by the way but I basically just took the
opportunity to check out the city on my
own and just kinda explore so I went to
Union Station checked out the Mexican
area the Chinatown area and even if it's
a little bit strange and weird feeling
that you've got all of these very
distinct communities of certain cultures
it's definitely really awesome to visit
these places it's really like you can be
in entirely different worlds in one day
also shout out to that amazing LA
traffic it's really as bad as the people
say it is Jesus in any case after that I
went up to the Griffith Observatory
because that's something that I feel you
have to do when you go to LA and of
course you got that great view of the
Hollywood sign and of the skyline of Los
Angeles downtown area in the background
but the observatory itself is pretty
awesome as well I didn't actually get
into the planetarium area itself but it
was still really cool to hang out there
but again I had to do some stuff when I
was in the hostel related to my city
skylights Oslo project but the next day
I went to Six Flags Magic Mountain now I
have to give huge thanks to Jake and
Joseph who actually brought me here
because this turned out to be one of the
best theme park trips ever I didn't need
to pay for entrance because it was
bringing your friend for free day and
they drove me into the park as well so
that was one of the easiest days I've
ever had and this is a huge bucket list
park with some awesome coasters like
Tatsu over here I'm just gonna go over
them really quickly I think Tatsu is a
fun coaster I don't think it's as good
as flying dinosaur it's a little bit
weak actually for my taste but a really
really cool write nonetheless especially
the way it interacts with the hills and
then we did Riddler's revenge and still
the park was really empty we were there
on the opening time but basically the
whole day almost everything was just no
queues whatsoever then we did Batman the
ride which was a huge positive surprise
a lot more intense than I thought and
definitely one of my favorite courses
that I've been on
and also scream which is the most
parking lot coaster ever apocalypse
which is like an old GTI woody which is
not good anymore or maybe it never was
we did Viper which I found to be
surprisingly good I know a lot of people
call this thing really rough but I don't
think it's that bad and I can definitely
see some classic value in this this is a
real classic roller coaster so I kind of
don't I kind of hope that they don't
remove it and we did Goliath which i
think is an underrated hyper doesn't
have much airtime it's good nonetheless
and full throttle which is great but it
is definitely really short it's over way
too quickly and revolution is one of my
favorite rides we ended up redoing this
in favor of some other coasters just
because I love that classics white cop
feel and that very circular loop so that
was really awesome that's it for my trip
to Los Angeles I ended up having another
day just to kind of travel home and get
my flights get up there in LAX because
God knows that my experience on that
Airport wasn't the best either but
overall that was an absolutely amazing
trip and once again huge thanks goes out
to frontier for paying for the flight
paying for the hotel I'm not really
afraid to say that because honestly I'm
just too thankful not to say it it
wasn't really a sponsored deal but so
I'm super happy that they were able to
take me there and huge thanks also to
all the amazing people were there Adam
Bowe of course but also some of the
great youtubers there and Jake and
Joseph were taking me to Six Flags Magic
Mountain by the way this is completely
unrelated footage of Shibuya that I
still had had to end up this video it's
something I didn't really have enough
shots even if this is not the most
representative vlogging video ever and
if it's just me commentating over some
of the shots that I took there I hope
you at least got a little bit of an idea
of when I managed to do in LA and what
the frontier event was like and I'd like
to thank you for watching and I'll see
you in the next theme park vlog which
hopefully I should be finishing a few
more in the up come
meantime I still have some footage from
folks like fuji-q highland and young you
real and and tobey's ooh on my computer
let us know wanna make some vlogs on it
see ya bye guys